e française les etats unis sont le pays
le plus touché au monde par l'épidémie
de coronavirus avec 338 milles patients
diagnostiqués
l'europe reste ce soir l'épicentre de la
pandémie avec 650 mille cas et 49 mille
morts la situation française est la
suivante 29 1722 personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisées pour
infection à coronavirus soit un solde de
831 patients supplémentaires par rapport
à hier 7072 cas graves nécessitent des
soins lourds en réanimation au cours des
24 dernières heures
quatre cent soixante dix huit nouveaux
patients ont été admis en réanimation il
a été nécessaire de prendre en charge
94 patients supplémentaires en tenant
compte des sorties quotidiennes
nombreuses ce besoin de trouver de
nouvelles places augmentent moins
rapidement que les jours précédents
je rappelle qu'il était de 140 patients
hier 176 samedi et que nous étions au
delà de 450 nouveaux patients en bilan
entrées sorties en réanimation dans les
hôpitaux français la semaine dernière
c'est un indicateur important parce que
c'est un indicateur de tension dans nos
hôpitaux et de mobilisation de toutes
les ressources humaines et logistiques
en outre-mer on relève 163
hospitalisations contre 155
hier dont 46 en réanimation et 136
patients guéris de retour à domicile
au total ce sont dix sept mille deux
cent cinquante personnes guéries qui ont
quitté l'hôpital
plus de mille patients supplémentaires
hier auxquels il faut ajouter les
dizaines de milliers de personnes
guéries en ville en établissement social
et médico-social 3865 établissements ont
d'ores et déjà signalé au moins un
épisode de cas de co vide à santé
publique france pour un total de 28 3620
patients diagnostiqués
la mortalité hospitalière depuis le 1er
mars fait que nous déplorons 6494 décès
à l'hôpital soit 605 décès à l'hôpital
de plus sur les 24 dernières heures en
ehpad et en établissement médico-social
nous déplorons 2417 décès survenus
depuis le début de l'épidémie
c'est à dire que depuis le 1er mars en
additionnant les décès à l'hôpital et en
établissement de santé social et médico
social
nous déplorons 8900 11 décès contre 8000
78 décès recensés hier
soit 8 133 décès de plus en 24 heures ou
dames et messieurs je sais combien les
français sont fiers
reconnaissant envers leur médecin leur
soignant leur ambulanciers leurs
pompiers ils voient les images de leur
exploit au quotidien sur leur écran de
télévision
lise les récits de journée sans fin dans
la presse soutiennent massivement leurs
blouses blanches sur les réseaux sociaux
ce soir je voudrais dire ô combien ils
méritent votre estime et votre
reconnaissance et votre admiration ce
qui a déjà été fait c'est du jamais vu
dans l'histoire contemporaine de la
france
une vocation qui confinent parfois je
n'ai pas peur du mot à l'héroïsme
héroïsme face à la maladie et face à la
mort nos soignants qu'il soit
hospitaliers publics ou privés libéraux
ou salariés en établissement de santé ou
dans des établissements et services
médico social sont ces héros de cette
lutte que nous livrons face aux
coronavirus comment mieux décrire cette
infirmière qui enchaîne les jours et les
nuits au chevet des malades jusqu'à
porter sur son visage les stigmates d'un
masque de protection
comment mieux décrire ces soignants qui
décident de quitter leur ville leur
famille pour rejoindre les territoires
où l'on a le plus besoin d'eux c'est
réanimateurs embarquer dans des avions
sanitaires pendant des heures pour
mettre leurs patients à l'abri dans un
hôpital parfois situé au bout de la
france
voir en allemagne ou en suisse leur
détermination est sans faille dans des
situations humaines qui porte tout en
elle
leur lot de souffrances pour les malades
comme pour leurs proches et je voudrais
vous dire cette innovation incroyable
qui se déploie jour après jour sur notre
territoire
l'innovation qui transforme des tgv en
ambulance géante qui élit porte qui
aviones qui naviguent celle qui fait
d'un simple lit d'hôpital une chambre de
réanimation avec ses équipements
indispensables respirateur pousse
seringue moniteur cardiaque
celle qui permet à des centaines de
milliers de patients de consulter leur
médecin par télémédecine voir par
téléphone jour après jour leur
mobilisation nous permet de surmonter le
pic épidémique que nous vivons ce n'est
pas terminé loin de là nous ne sommes
pas au bout de l'ascension épidémique
le chemin reste long et rien n'est fini
les chiffres que je vous ai présenté il
ya quelques minutes le démontre je vous
dis cela parce que ce soir comme hier et
comme demain ce que nous devons en
retour à nos héros c'est de continuer
notre mobilisation de citoyens tout
aussi précieuse pour sauver des vies
tout aussi vital en restant chez nous ce
qui permet à nos hôpitaux de tenir dans
des conditions parfois extrêmes mais de
tenir
c'est aussi la préparation de nos
hôpitaux
je fais référence ici à la
déprogrammation massive des soins non
urgents à l'activation précoce du plan
blanc partout sur le territoire
j'ai toujours eu conscience que nos
hôpitaux était moderne capable de tous
les exploits
il nous le démontre chaque jour nous
savons tous que l'hôpital de demain ne
pourra pas être exactement l'hôpital
d'hyères cette crise sanitaire traduit
aussi la nécessité de réinventer le
modèle de l'hôpital qui devra pour
l'avenir être mieux armée pour gérer
toute crise épidémique de cette ampleur
avec les moyens et les organisations
pour cela il faut regarder la situation
elle qu'elle est et constater que la
crise du coc vide 19 change la donne
hospitalière et ce changement s'inscrira
à n'en pas douter dans la durée au
sortir de la crise il conviendra donc au
delà de l'indispensable reconnaissance
due aux personnels hospitaliers qui
auront démontré à la nation tout entière
combien elle leur doit de réinterroger
en profondeur nos réflexes et nos
matières de pan et nos manières de
penser en matière de gestion
hospitalière pour préparer le grand plan
d'investissement dans notre système de
santé que le président de la république
a annoncé à mulhouse le 26 mars dernier
d'ici là il convient de considérer avec
humilité les projets les réorganisations
engagées avant cette crise et d'en
suspendre toute la portée
jusqu'à ce que l'inventaire de cette
épidémie tout l'inventaire et pu être
effectué avec tous les soignants
car l'hôpital devra s'armer pour
répondre avec résilience aux épidémies
tout en poursuivant ses missions
fondamentales notamment vis-à-vis des
maladies chroniques ou des pathologies
fonctionnel je sais c'est d'ailleurs
cette occasion pour rappeler chaque
français qui nécessitent des soins
essentiels en dehors du coronavirus à
contacter son médecin et le cas échéant
son hôpital pour ne pas retarder
indûment une prise en charge dont le
report pourrait lui causer du tort j'ai
entendu parler de suivi de grossesse
interrompu de dépistage du cancer non
réalisés ou de vaccination infantile
retardé je souhaite appeler chaque
français à revenir vers son médecin pour
que ces actes essentiels continue d'être
assurée notamment à distance à chaque
fois que c'est possible
alors que la vague de patients atteints
du coronavirus atteint les réanimations
il ne faudrait surtout pas que d'autres
malades renoncent à des soins essentiels
dans la période
car les conséquences sanitaires
pourraient être lourdes aussi j'insiste
sur la nécessité pour ces personnes de
continuer à consulter leur médecin
traitant
mais également leurs médecins
spécialistes
organes tels que cardiologue un
pneumologue ou encore endocrinologue
dans la plupart des cas une simple télé
consultation par téléphone même peut
d'ailleurs suffire ce qui n'empêche pas
que si vous devez vous faire dépister un
cancer cancer du sein par mammographie
cancer colorectal faites le si vous
devez faire vacciner votre enfant faites
le si vous avez un diabète ou toute
autre maladie chronique et que vous
devez avoir un suivi
faites-le nous avons mis en place des
dispositifs permettant de faciliter le
suivi des personnes atteintes de
maladies chroniques
je le disais la télésanté avec les
téléconsultations mais également le thé
les soins pour les infirmiers ou bientôt
d'autres professionnels de la
rééducation comme les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes la possibilité
également de prolonger les ordonnances
de médicaments ou de soins infirmiers
pour les malades chroniques en période
de confinement l'attestation de
déplacement dérogatoire précise bien
d'ailleurs que vous avez le droit de
consulter votre médecin
notamment lorsque vous avez une
affection de longue durée
je m'adresse aussi aux médecins qu'ils
soient généralistes ou d'autres
spécialités pour leur dire je sais que
beaucoup le font déjà
n'hésitez pas à rappeler vos patients
assurez vous que le suivi est maintenu
et qu'il n'y a pas de risque de
décompensation d'une maladie chronique
[Musique]
j'entends par ailleurs les demandes de
certains hôpitaux de certaines cliniques
situées dans des territoires où le virus
circule peu et qui souhaite désormais
amplifié certaines activités de soins
qui n'engage pas de moyens humains ou
matériels indispensables dans la guerre
contre le colis de 19 je tiens à leur
dire que nous évaluons toutes ses
demandes
mais au vu de ce que nous connaissons
dans les territoires sous forte tension
comme en ile de france
je souhaite qu'un maximum de moyens
restent mobilisés par solidarité samedi
dernier je me suis adressé avec sophie
cluzel à l'ensemble du secteur du
handicap
je voudrais évoquer ce soir la situation
des personnes âgées en
d'autonomie qu'elle soit à domicile ou
en ehpad
c'est un sujet qui inquiète profondément
et c'est normal les français avant toute
chose je voudrais rendre un hommage tout
particulier aux plus de huit cent mille
professionnels du grand âge que ce soit
à domicile ou en établissement
ils ont en commun d'être en première
ligne tout au long de l'année auprès des
personnes âgées et de se battre pour
sauvegarder leur autonomie leur santé
leur sécurité leur liberté et leur joie
de vivre
aujourd'hui cette première ligne
revêtent un sens tout particulier avec
les proches aidants qui accompagnent au
quotidien à nos aînés ils sont les
gardiens de ceux qui sont le plus
fragile face au virus je voudrais leur
dire aujourd'hui que l'enfant leur
engagement les honneurs chaque jour dans
les ehpad les résidences autonomie les
résidences services ou les unités de
soins de longue durée mais aussi les
services à domicile ils se rendent
auprès de nos aînés pour les protéger
avec un professionnalisme et une
humanité qui force mon admiration
personnelle est qu'ils doivent forcer
l'admiration de tous les français il se
bat pour éviter que le virus n'entre
dans les ehpad et je veux rappeler que
les deux tiers des ehpad n'ont déclaré
aucun cas grâce justement à la vigilance
extrême de ces professionnels il faut le
marteler les morts nous bouleverse
mais cette bataille n'est pas perdue ce
n'est pas vrai nous nous battons pied à
pied pour protéger les résidents
là où le virus est entré les
professionnels mène une toute autre
guerre il lutte contre sa propagation
et pour soigner les malades et nous leur
devons un soutien sans faille
il ya une semaine nous avons annoncé le
renforcement des mesures de protection
au sein des ehpad la mobilisation de
ressources extérieures pour que les
établissements ne reste jamais seul dans
la prise en charge la création de
filières d'hospitalisation spécifique
pour les personnes âgées
dès maintenant et dans les jours à venir
nous mettrons un accent particulier sur
les renforts humains en mobilisant à
grande échelle la réserve sanitaire en
facilitant l'intervention des médecins
et infirmiers libéraux dans les
établissements et en mobilisant toutes
les ressources locales
je voudrais aussi revenir aujourd'hui
sur un point particulier c'est le sujet
du dépistage
nous sommes en train de doubler notre
capacité de tests par pcr je voulais
déjà dit ce qui nous permet de lancer
une vaste opération de dépistage des
personnes les plus vulnérables en
mettant la priorité sur les personnes
âgées les personnes handicapées les plus
fragiles ainsi que les professionnels
qui les accompagnent en établissement
comme à domicile
le principe est le suivant tester tous
les résidents et tous les personnels à
compter de l'apparition du premier cas
confirmés de malades de coronavirus au
sein de l'établissement
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir s'organiser
de la manière la plus sécurisée possible
cela permettra notamment de regrouper
les cas positifs au sein de secteurs
dédiés au sein des ehpad pour éviter les
comptines les contaminations des autres
résidents cela permettra aussi de
prendre des dispositions appropriées à
l'égard du personnel selon les résultats
des tests
vous le savez il est possible d'être
testés positifs sans ressentir pour
autant le moindre symptôme et en pouvant
donc travailler mais le savoir permet de
prendre de meilleures décisions
d'organisation par exemple en permettant
au personnel positif mais
asymptomatiques de travailler au sein
des unités regroupement des personnes
déjà malades en sachant nous serons
mieux armé pour permettre cette
opération de dépistage à grande échelle
nous mettrons en place des moyens de
projection importants au sein même des
établissements avec les laboratoires
vous savez que j'ai autorisé l'ensemble
des laboratoires de ce pays à pouvoir
participer à l'effort de dépistage
national mais aussi en associant la
réserve sanitaire et en travaillant
localement avec les conseils
départementaux
je me suis entretenu avec dominique
bussereau président de l'association des
départements français qui m'a assuré du
plein et entier soutien des départements
pour pouvoir mener dès demain des
actions massives de dépistage dans tous
les établissements et je sais que
beaucoup d'élus locaux je me suis
entretenu à ce sujet avec la maire de
paris ce matin sont tout à fait prêts à
mener cette bataille à nos côtés et je
les en remercie
des équipes mobiles seront enfin mis en
place des bus de prélèvements seront
créés et déployer partout où cela
nécessaire cela est nécessaire
je vous le redis dans la bataille que
nous menons contre le coronavirus la
protection des publics les plus fragiles
et la priorité des priorités pour nous
je vous remercie je vais peut-être
prendre quelques questions trois
questions la plus merci une question
pour le monde attend une estimation de
l'impact du confinement
à combien estime-t-on la proportion de
la population qui a déjà été infectées
ces deux questions importantes et très
longue vous répondre que la semaine
dernière j'ai communiqué les chiffres
d'un institut anglais qui s'appelle
l'impérial college of london et qui
estimait déjà à 2500 vies sauvées
l'impact du confinement c'est-à-dire qui
décimait que toutes les 8 minutes
nous avions permis de sauver une vie en
restant chez nous l'impact du
confinement il est visible dans les
territoires où le circule le virus
circule beaucoup puisque la pression qui
est encore très forte
énorme sur les hôpitaux c'est pour ça
que je dis bien que confinement doit se
poursuivre j'entends les questions des
français sur la suite et je les
comprends mais l'heure est resté chez
nous et à poursuivre cet effort de
confinement on le voit ce confinement
atteint à un impact visible palpable
en france on commence à le sentir à
l'étranger là où le confinement a été
mis en oeuvre parce que l'épidémie avait
commencé plus tôt nous avons aussi la
conviction que ce confinement permet
permet de sauver des vies une question
pour france info martin hirsch a dit ce
matin que l'effet du confinement était
en deçà de ce que les experts
attendaient
est ce que vous confirmez et attend
atteint le plateau espérer je redis pour
que les les français comprennent
l'impact du confinement
il ya ce qu'on appelle sans rentrer trop
dans les détails à ce qu'on appelle le
r0 le r0 c'est la capacité de quelqu'un
qui contaminait à contaminer d'autres
personnes
si le r0 est supérieur à 1 ça veut dire
qu'un malade va contaminer plus d'une
personne et donc que l'épidémie va
prendre de l'ampleur
si le héros est inférieur à 1 ça veut
dire que petit à petit les malades
contaminés moins deux personnes et donc
l'épidémie peut s'atténuer voir
disparaître
nous avons beaucoup de modélisation
françaises étrangères et beaucoup de
calculs de cas sur l'ensemble du
territoire
les derniers chiffres qui me remonte
mais qui sont à prendre avec beaucoup de
précaution atteste que grâce à l'effet
du confinement ce fameux airs 0 et aux
alentours de 1 et probablement un peu en
dessous et dans certaines régions il est
même nettement en dessous de 1
dans d'autres territoires il reste
supérieur à 1 raison pour laquelle il
faut continuer à rester chez nous je ne
le répèterai jamais assez et raison pour
laquelle il faut encore amplifier notre
capacité de patience dans cette période
difficile parce que c'est à ce titre
qu'on est capable de faire tomber ce
héros en dessous de 1 et de faire en
sorte que l'épidémie nous puissions
l'abattre mais deux autres paramètres
d'une épidémie nous ne pouvons pas les
maîtriser c'est la contagiosité d'un
virus et c'est la durée pendant laquelle
on est contagieux quand on était
contaminée
le seul paramètre qu'on maîtrise
pleinement c'est celui de la
distanciation sociale grâce au
confinement est la dernière question le
quotidien du pharmacien les pharmaciens
ont fait deux demandes au ministère de
la santé la première l'autorisation de
vendre des masques alternatif au grand
public la seconde de participer à la
réalisation des tests sérologiques
quelle est la réponse du ministère c'est
si elle est positive
à quelle échéance depuis le premier jour
de cette crise à chaque fois que j'ai
été interpellé par des professionnels de
santé qui m'ont fait une demande nous
avons toujours examiner la demande et
sauf rare exception justifiée
j'ai toujours donné un accord est un
accord rapide souvenez-vous lorsque les
pharmaciens ont demandé à pouvoir
fabriquer eux mêmes les solutions
hydro-alcooliques ils ont été autorisés
à le faire lorsque des laboratoires
départementaux vétérinaire scientifique
de police ou de gendarmerie ont demandé
à pouvoir eux aussi participer à
l'effort national de test j'ai pris un
décret pour les autoriser à le faire
toute demande est examinée la question
des tests sérologiques elle relève
surtout de notre capacité à disposer de
ces tests non pas parce que la france ne
serait pas capable de les avoir mais
elle dépend de la recherche et de
l'innovation qui est en train d'aboutir
et nous avons des procédés de tests
sérologiques qui seront bientôt mature
et que nous allons pouvoir
commandé puis distribuer les réseaux de
distribution pourront éventuellement
associé des pharmaciens je regarderai ça
avec la plus grande attention
s'agissant enfin de la question des
masques non soignants attention encore
une fois il ya de la vigilance sur cette
question qui est fondamentale et que je
comprends qu'elles intéressent au plus
haut point les français elle m'intéresse
et comme citoyen et comme médecins et
comme ministre de la santé
je rappelle que les masques médicaux
chirurgicaux et ffp2 sont réservés à un
public et notamment les soignants et les
personnes fragiles que le prémunit que
le premier ministre a annoncé qu'il y
avait des masques qui sont des masques
non soignants destiné aux français de ce
qu'on appelle la deuxième ligne ce sont
des personnes qui sont au contact avec
du public et qui ont besoin d'avoir une
protection particulière et que par
ailleurs la réflexion sur le port du
masque en population générale
cette fameuse question qui soulève
beaucoup d'autres questions à l'étranger
nous sommes en train de la regarder
comme nous le faisons depuis le début
avec humilité face à un risque inconnu
qui est cette épidémie virale avec
humilité face à l'évolution des données
qui nous reviennent tant au niveau
national que depuis l'étranger j'entends
que certains pays ne prône le port du
masque en population générale j'entends
aussi que des organismes internationaux
comme l'organisation mondiale de la
santé considère que le port du masque et
ne doit surtout pas pénaliser les gestes
barrière qui sont encore plus
protecteurs je nous saisissons les
autorités scientifiques de ce pays pour
leur demander si la doctrine doit
évoluer
étant donné que la vie d'un certain
nombre de scientifiques a pu évoluer je
n'ai pas la réponse à l'heure à laquelle
je vous parle mais je vous promets de
vous la donner dans les meilleurs délais
c'est une question dont je comprends
encore une fois qu'elle intéresse les
français
il n'y a pas de changement radical des
doctrines il ya toujours une évolution
une capacité à nous adapter
collectivement face encore une fois à ce
qui relève je le redis avec humilité
d'une menace épidémique que nous ne
connaissions pas que le monde n'avait
jamais connu jusqu'à présent
jean merci